[MUSIC PLAYING]
KEVIN GOVER: So as you
heard, my name's Kevin Gover.
I'm the director of the National
Museum of the American Indian.
If I lapse into jargon,
I'll say "NMAI,"
because it sort of
rolls off my tongue now.
But that's our museum.
The NMAI is a
Smithsonian Museum.
We were, I believe, the
19th of the now 20 museums
and research centers that are
part of the Smithsonian system.
It is by far the largest
museum complex in the world.
Most of our museums are located
in Washington, but not all.
And our most recent
addition to the Smithsonian
was the National Museum of
African American History
and Culture.
So as you heard, I am the
director of the museum.
What might surprise
you about me is
that I was trained as a lawyer.
I went to law school.
And I actually practiced
law for a number of years
and really liked it.
I can't yet account for
why I'm not still a lawyer,
except that I got
this opportunity
to come to the Smithsonian
and run the National
Museum of the American Indian.
Let me give you a brief
history of our museum.
In the early 1900s, there
was a wealthy New Yorker
named George Gustav Heye.
And Mr. Heye was part of
the Standard Oil fortune.
That seems to be where
he made his money.
But he developed, for reasons
we haven't quite teased out,
a passion for collecting Native
American ethnographic material.
Now, what was going on at
this time in the world--
or in the Native world--
was that there was a presumption
that Native Americans would
soon fade into
history and that there
would no longer be American
Indians in the United States.
Not only was that
thought to be true,
it was quite deliberately
hoped that it would be
true by the federal government.
And policies that the
government set up at the time
were really intended to see that
the tribes simply faded away
and that Native Americans would
no longer be a distinct part
of the American population.
It wasn't so much extermination
as it was assimilation,
and it was quite literally
called an assimilation policy.
So the anthropologists and
scholars of the time, these
are the folks that brought
us such insights as the race
science, where they
were measuring skulls
to determine the brain pan
capacity of the different races
and, from that,
drawing some pretty
broad conclusions
about the intelligence
of the different races.
But these fellows
were in a near panic,
because if Indians
were going to go away,
there was not any time to lose
in collecting their material
culture and learning
about these societies
that they had created.
So Mr. Heye was a
part of that movement
that we now call
salvage anthropology
and spent his fortune moving
around not just the United
States, but also Canada and
Central and South America,
collecting what remained
of Native American material
culture at that time, so much
so that he managed to collect,
by the mid-1900s, a collection
of around 800,000 items.
At first, he was keeping all of
these things in his apartment
there in New York,
which we have to assume
was a fairly large apartment.
But a few hundred
thousand items would
be a little much for anyone.
So his wife said, you
know, this isn't working.
It's either these things
have to go, or I have to go.
So his second wife, fortunately,
was more open to his passion.
And we have some
cute pictures of them
out on archaeological
expeditions together wearing
the pith helmets and everything.
Very much a love story.
So Mr. Heye opened his museum
in New York City in 1916.
And he passed away in the
1950s and left, really,
a quite handsomely
endowed museum
behind with one of the, if
not the, greatest collection
of Native American
material in the world
and in a good endowment
for continuing operations.
Unfortunately, by the
1980s, the character
of the neighborhood where
he had built this museum--
this was at 155th Street
and Broadway in New York--
was not what it once was,
and attendance at the museum
collapsed.
And they were still
dependent on charging people
to get into their museum in
order to finance operations.
So long story short,
the collection
was in some considerable risk
of being broken apart and sold.
It was at that point
that there were
several Native American members
of the board of the Museum
of the American Indian,
and they very much
wanted to see this
collection not just rescued,
but that it become the backbone
of a new Smithsonian National
Museum of the American Indian.
And so after a lot of
haggling and a lot of drama
and a lot of
politics, the powers
that be in New York City,
New York state, the US
Senate, and the House of
Representatives, and finally,
the Smithsonian
Institution itself
came together and
struck a grand bargain
by which the assets of the
Heye Foundation's museum,
the Museum of the
American Indian,
would be transferred
to the Smithsonian.
And the Smithsonian would
establish a National Museum
of the American Indian.
There were two important
conditions for our purposes.
One was that the
Smithsonian and the National
Museum of the American
Indian always have
a location in New York City.
And so we are the only
Smithsonian Museum
with separate locations in
both Washington and New York.
Our New York location, for those
of you who travel to New York,
is down by Battery Park.
It's in the Alexander
Hamilton US Custom
House, which is a glorious old
Beaux-Arts building literally
across the street
from Battery Park.
It was also a condition
that the Smithsonian
would build a state
of the art facility
for the care and maintenance
of the Heye collection.
And the National Museum of
the American Indian did that.
We have a beautiful facility
in Suitland, Maryland,
just outside of Washington,
which is now home to Mr. Heye's
collection.
And then finally, the advocacy
of the Native American people
on the board required
that there be
a museum on the National Mall.
Now, that was no small
matter, because at that time,
it was thought there was only
one place on the National Mall
where there would be
another Smithsonian Museum.
And that's at the corner of 3rd
Street and Independence Avenue.
The Smithsonian had
in mind that they
were going to build
what was quaintly
referred to back in the
1980s as a "museum of man."
What that really is,
aside from the sexist
title, is an anthropology
museum to examine cultures
from all over the
world, blah, blah, blah.
So it would have been just
another anthropology museum.
But it would be a Smithsonian
anthropology museum,
so it was no small matter.
Over time, the
Smithsonian was persuaded
that its interests lay
with having a National
Museum of the American Indian.
There were some very
powerful members of Congress
who supported the idea and
basically told the Smithsonian,
you are going to do this.
And eventually, the
Smithsonian agreed.
And so the National Museum
of the American Indian
was established by
Congress in 1989.
We opened our museum
in New York in 1994,
opened the Cultural
Resources Center
in Suitland, the home of
the collections, in 1999,
and opened our museum on
the National Mall in 2004.
On the day of the opening of
the museum on the National Mall,
they estimate there were
about 25,000 Native Americans
from all over North, South,
and Central America who
attended that opening.
And it was really quite a sight.
Newspapers being
what they are, they
were saying things like, this
is the most Indians that have
ever, ever been in this area.
And of course, there's no
way for us to know that.
But it's the thought
that counts, I suppose.
So we'll just kind
of go with it.
So that's how we came to be.
And the museum is
doing all the things
you would expect a museum
to do in this day and age.
We, of course, take good
care of our collections.
We have exhibitions in
both of our museums.
Between the two, we draw about--
a little short of 2
million visitors a year
come to our museums.
We do programs,
cultural art programs,
as well as educational programs.
We have an online presence
that we're constantly
trying to upgrade and
make a lot more vibrant.
But we are now very much
a mainstream museum.
The museum did accomplish
two extraordinarily important
things in its early years.
One was that, under
the legislation
that established the
museum, both the National
Museum of the American
Indian and the National
Museum of Natural History,
which is one of the oldest
museums in the system, were
required to begin immediately
returning to Native
American communities
human remains that originated
in those communities.
The Smithsonian had
collections of something
like 18,000 sets
of human remains
that had been collected mostly
in the late 19th century, many
of them from
battlefields, many of them
from graveyards
that were identified
as the country moved west.
And they were dug up, packaged
up, and sent back to Washington
to be a part of the
collections of the Smithsonian.
When Senator Daniel Inouye
of Hawaii learned about this,
he was mortified and outraged.
And it wasn't much challenged
that those things, those
remains, should be returned to
their originating communities.
The mandate was later expanded
to include sacred objects that
were in the possession
of the Smithsonian
and objects of
cultural patrimony.
And so both of the two
museums, now, Natural History
and American Indian, maintain
active repatriation programs.
And we are returning things
that, in all honesty,
never should have left
those communities.
So it's an interesting
exercise in trying
to correct a historical wrong.
The other thing the
museum did that I
think is tremendously
important and that
now seems a little bit,
again, rather quaint
is the idea that Native
American people themselves
ought to be involved
in the interpretation
of their material culture
and their history.
Now, that hopefully
seems really,
really obvious to all of you
that that is as it should be.
But it was a genuinely
revolutionary concept
in the early 1990s, because
traditionally, the practice
had been that experts--
almost all non-Indian experts--
would study the material
culture of a community
and go out and interview
the Indian people
and then come back and
report to the world,
this is who these
people are, and these
are the things they
believe in, and this is why
they do things the way they do.
Well, it probably
doesn't surprise
you to learn that they
quite often, perhaps even
most of the time, got it wrong.
Because when you don't actually
involve Native people directly
in the curation
of this material,
you're almost certainly going
to get large parts of it wrong.
Nevertheless, it
was museum practice
throughout the country, and
still is in places like Europe,
that non-Indian
experts would be given
the authority to interpret
Native American culture.
The museum came out of the box
basically saying, that's wrong.
That is exactly the
wrong way to do it.
The only legitimate way, the
only proper, scholarly method
for examining these
cultures and this material,
is to involve Native American
people themselves directly
in that interpretation.
And what seemed like a
radical concept 25 years ago
is now very much
mainstream museum practice.
And I think, wow, that movement
had begun before the NMAI came
into existence.
It certainly
accelerated, and the fact
that it was a Smithsonian Museum
that was saying these things
really made all the difference
in getting the museum
world to change its ways.
So we do all the usual
things that a museum does.
We have lots of
wonderful exhibitions,
and we quarrel with the critics
over whether they're good
or not.
But what I want
to talk more about
is how we're trying to reach
out beyond the museum walls.
Obviously, that takes
place through technology.
And I will hasten
to add that we are
in no way, shape, or form,
at this time, masters
of the technology.
The Smithsonian somehow
managed to fall 10 or 15 years
behind the rest of the world.
And it really is
quite curious to me.
I came aboard at
the museum in 2007.
Not that I'm a
technological expert,
but I was surprised
to see that we
were doing little more than
the basics at the Smithsonian.
Everybody had a website.
I sort of think about the
Smithsonian in the '90s
and think how amazed
everybody must have
been at something like email.
Because this is an old place.
It will be celebrating its 175th
anniversary in 2021, I believe.
And there's a reason
that the dinosaur exhibit
at the Smithsonian is so famous,
because it sort of embodies
the essence of how we
are, especially when it
comes to technology.
But having said that, we
are trying to do better.
One of our projects is
called Native Knowledge 360.
And this is an
attempt to address
what Olivia was talking about,
that Native American students
are not doing well.
And I believe much of the
reason they're not doing well
is that they simply don't see
themselves in the curriculum
as it's being taught now.
When I was growing up
and learning in school,
I remember not
learning a single thing
in school that made me
proud of my ancestors.
And I think that was the
experience of most people
my age.
And it was distressing,
when we undertook
a study of the textbooks that
are in use across the country,
to learn that they really
haven't changed very much.
There might be just a
smidge more material,
but Native Americans still
disappear from the history
books around 1900, never to
be seen or heard from again,
almost as though the American
policy of assimilation
had succeeded in doing
away with all the Indians.
At the same time,
weirdly, our visitors
don't come to our
museums as blank slates.
They come there knowing
something about Indians,
because there are still things
about Indians sort of out
in the ether.
Certainly, there is
in the curriculum
of the public schools.
And in the popular
culture, there
is still a lot about Indians.
And of course, the problem
is that those ideas,
when they're not incomplete,
are almost entirely false.
But our visitors
come to the museum
believing them and thinking
that, I know all about this.
And museum visitors
are kind of weird,
because one of the reasons
they come to a museum
is they want to see
what they already
know confirmed by an authority.
And interestingly,
museums are still
regarded as one of the most
authoritative and credible
institutions in the country.
While many of others have
suffered quite dramatically,
whether it be our political
bodies or the media, even
universities, museums
are still kind of held
in very high regard.
And so if you go to a museum
and you see something,
then you can say, I knew that.
Then that makes you a
really smart guy, right?
And so we had to
deal with visitors
who were coming to our museum
and saying, what is this?
We have no idea what this is.
Because we weren't sort
of playing to the things
they already know.
And it doesn't
just bewilder them.
It kind of makes them mad
and is off-putting to them.
So we began thinking about--
one possible response
we could have is,
hey, we're the experts now,
and so just shut up and listen.
That's usually not the
road to persuading somebody
of what you're trying to say.
And so we thought, well, let's
maybe talk about these stories
that they know and see if
we can help them gain more
understanding by that method.
So you probably all
know the stories
that I'm going to talk about.
If you had to say, what
are the five things
every American knows about
Native American history?
Most often, they're
going to include
things like the first
Thanksgiving, of course.
That, by the way, is why
November is Native American
Heritage Month, isn't it?
Because this is the
time of year when we all
think about Indians, right?
Another would be Pocahontas.
And you notice how sturdy
Pocahontas' presence
in the American culture is
when she's back in the news
and it's 2018, when she
died nearly 400 years ago.
Some of the other stories
would be Little Bighorn,
of course, which is weird,
because it was a crushing
defeat for the American army.
And yet people love this
story about Little Bighorn.
And we're really
curious about that.
In fact, I think of some
of our work as being,
we're doing anthropology
on white people
to try to understand
their strange beliefs
and their strange culture
and how they view themselves.
And that's kind of fun for us.
So seriously, we started
thinking about, well,
why are these
stories so powerful?
One of the things that we began
thinking about is every culture
has origin myths.
Every culture has
a way of saying,
this is where we come from,
because that's about who
we are, right, as a people.
So we started thinking about
origin myths of the United
States.
And if you thought about
it for just a minute,
you would come up with
several of them, right?
Certainly Columbus
discovering America.
That's part of the
American origin myth.
Even though Columbus never
set foot in North America,
he is still claimed as
the discoverer of America.
But others, maybe a
little more subtle,
are things like the first
Thanksgiving, right?
If you're in New England, that
is the American origin myth
in New England.
Everybody knows about
the first Thanksgiving.
Everybody knows
where Plymouth is.
Everybody knows the story of
Squanto, the friendly Indian
who taught the Pilgrims to
grow corn, blah, blah, blah.
In our part of the world down in
the DC area, the mid-Atlantic,
the origin myth is
Pocahontas and Jamestown.
And everybody knows
the story of Pocahontas
in that part of the country.
And I got curious.
As we sort of move
across the country,
the origin myths are
always different.
And they're changing.
So here in California,
there are a couple
of very powerful origin myths.
One is the Spanish missions
spreading up and down
the state.
But the other, of
course, is the gold rush.
And these are California's
origin stories.
It explains how the
state came to be
and why we're so
special, because we
are the descendants of these
people who did these things.
Anyway, so we're thinking
about, OK, well, this
is why they know those stories.
What is it about those
stories that's so special?
By the way, we know that these
are origin myths of the United
States, because if you
go into the castle--
the castle-- into the
Capitol of the United States,
in the rotunda--
the castle's what we refer to
Smithsonian headquarters as.
It's a red castle building, so
that was a slip of the tongue.
In the Capitol, in
the rotunda, there
are eight very
large paintings sort
of circling around
the Capitol rotunda.
And of those, several
involve Indians.
One, the most
striking, perhaps, is
there is a huge painting of
the baptism of Pocahontas.
So Pocahontas is clearly
a Founding Mother
of the United States.
Another is the "Embarkation
of the Pilgrims."
It wasn't the
first Thanksgiving.
It was when the Pilgrims left
Europe to come to the New World
seeking religious liberty.
Another, my personal
favorite, is De Soto
discovering the Mississippi.
And it's an
interesting painting,
because there's a whole
Indian village there
that De Soto is standing in.
And I thought, and they never
noticed the Mississippi River
right here?
So De Soto discovers
the Mississippi.
Anyway, these are
origin myths, right?
These are the stories we tell
ourselves about ourselves
that make us feel special.
So let's start looking
at a couple of them.
One is the first Thanksgiving.
We all know the story.
The Pilgrims arrive.
They almost starve to
death that first winter.
Then the friendly
Indian, Squanto,
shows up to teach
them how to grow corn.
And later that year, they're
thriving, and they're happy,
and they're well fed.
And they decide, let's
have our Indian friends
over for a harvest feast at
the end of our first year
to give thanks for
our good fortune.
So that's a fine story, right?
Kind of makes you feel good.
There's the hardiness
of these first Americans
that have arrived.
And they were fleeing
religious bigotry.
There's even a touch of
racial harmony in this story.
And so it's like, yeah,
that's who we are.
This is part of us.
Well, as you would
expect, because we are,
after all, just
human beings, it's
a little more complex and
a lot more messy than that.
But it is a really cool story.
And so it's true.
The Pilgrims arrived in--
why you would want to
land in a new world
in a climate like that in
November is quite beyond me.
But that's what they did.
And so naturally, they
almost starved to death,
because they weren't able
to grow food that year.
What they did do was find
the winter stashes of corn
that a nearby Wampanoag
village had stored.
And they literally
survived on this.
You're asking, so why
did the Wampanoag let
them have all that corn?
They were all dead.
They had died.
A smallpox epidemic had
moved through the area
immediately before the
arrival of the Pilgrims.
And so there it was,
there for the taking.
A second element to the
story is Squanto himself.
Everybody know about Squanto?
Did everybody
learned that story?
No, OK.
Well, Squanto is the famous
friendly Indian, right?
Well his real name
was Tisquantum.
And he wasn't quite as friendly
as they make him out to be.
But he's an interesting
guy, because when
the Pilgrims arrived,
Tisquantum spoke English.
Now, how did that happen, right?
The Pilgrims are supposed
to be the first Englishmen
to show up in the New World,
and there's this Indian guy
going, hey, what's up?
I mean, that would have freaked
me out if I were one of them,
right?
But yeah, what had
happened is Tisquantum
had been kidnapped and taken
aboard an English fishing
boat--
and they were fishing the
North Atlantic at the time--
carried back to Europe as a
slave, and later was redeemed.
The Crown was dismayed when they
learned that this had happened.
And he made his way back.
He was brought back to his town
there in Massachusetts only
to discover that they had
been wiped out by smallpox.
So now, Tisquantum
is there, and he
becomes the go-between
between the Pilgrims
and the Wampanoag
Confederacy in the area.
So now, we've got a more
interesting story, right?
Because it wasn't just,
Squanto the friendly Indian
comes in and grunts and does
sign language to communicate.
But in fact, he's
negotiating with them
and engaging,
literally, in diplomacy
with these newcomers who were
welcomed by the Wampanoags,
because the Wampanoags
had just suffered mightily
in the smallpox epidemic.
And the surrounding
tribes and confederacies
smelled their weakness, and so
the Wampanoags needed allies.
And the Pilgrims could be
very formidable allies,
and so they did.
And as it happens,
a year later, they
did, in fact, have a meal
together, have a celebration,
with both sides bringing
food and just having
a good old time.
They played a little
football, as we do now.
And it was great.
It was great.
A good time was had by all.
But it didn't happen
the year after that.
I mean, there wasn't an
annual Thanksgiving feast
where they go,
hey, remember when
we had the Indians come over?
Let's do that again this year.
It didn't happen.
So this thing happened in 1621.
And it was literally 200
years before it actually
came to the attention
of the American people
again as a thing.
And they found an
old journal that was
kept by one of the Pilgrims.
And this old journal,
in a single sentence,
a single phrase, said,
the Indians came over,
and we had a feast.
That's it.
That's all that
was said about it.
But now, we have this whole
Thanksgiving industrial complex
built up, right, where we all
know what we're supposed to do.
We're supposed to eat a lot on
Thursday, shop a lot on Friday,
watch football on
Saturday and Sunday.
Because that's what you
do if you're an American.
And we base it all on this
thing that happened in 1621.
And so that's sort of
interesting how all of that
works.
The rest of the story
is not quite so happy.
And it kind of blows up
the Thanksgiving thing,
because about 40 years later,
the Pilgrims and the Wampanoags
engaged in what was probably
the most devastating war ever
fought in North America--
devastating in terms
of the percentage
of the two peoples
that were killed
in the engagement.
It was called King Philip's War.
There came a point where the
Pilgrims and their successors
kept coming and saying, we
need a little more land.
Can you hook us up?
And the Wampanoags were
going, well, you know,
we're getting really
short, but damn, that's
some nice stuff
you're offering us.
So we're going to take it.
Until the point came where
the Wampanoags could no longer
survive on the land that they
had, and the Pilgrims were not
showing any interest in being
helpful to them at that point,
because they had
what they wanted.
And so there was a war.
And it was absolutely
devastating
to the New England tribes.
The chief of the
Wampanoags, King Philip,
as he was called by the English,
was ultimately captured.
His head was put on a pike
at the entrance to Plymouth
and stayed there for 20 years.
And so that's not the same
story as the first Thanksgiving,
right?
But they're really inseparable.
And it seems like we should
know all of those things.
Let me tell you one more that's
a little bit-- well, maybe
a little bit more uplifting.
And that is the
story of Pocahontas.
So Pocahontas was real.
But if you learned
it the way I did,
we all know that
Pocahontas saved
John Smith from the
Jamestown colony
from being executed by
her evil father, Powhatan,
and went on to marry him.
And so here, again, we have
all these cool elements
of a good origin myth, right?
We have this interracial
harmony idea again.
And we have a love
story to boot.
So this is a good story.
And you have a beautiful
young Indian woman
in her buckskin cocktail dress
talking to animals and singing
songs.
So it's nice, right?
But I'm sure you won't
be surprised to learn
that's not quite what happened.
As it happens,
Pocahontas was 11 years
old when she first met John
Smith, who was 28 at the time.
There was, in fact, an
engagement between the Powhatan
Confederacy and the
Jamestown colonists,
who survived only because
they were provided food
by the Indians.
But the rest of it is a lot
messier than we might hope.
Pocahontas did not, in
fact, marry John Smith.
And historians now agree that
it's extraordinarily unlikely
that she saved his life from
being executed for two reasons.
The only written
source for this story
was a book that John
Smith himself wrote,
and I'm afraid he
was known to be
a terrible liar and
the hero, of course,
of every one of his stories.
So there is reason
to be skeptical.
The other thing, though,
is that he wrote a book
about a similar adventure in the
Middle East, where, would you
believe it, the exact
same thing happened where
a local princess
saved him from being
executed by her evil father.
And so that that struck
everybody as probably not true.
So none of that happened.
What did happen, though,
was that Pocahontas
married a man named John Rolfe.
She did convert to Christianity.
The sources are mixed.
Different people would
tell you different stories
about just how voluntary
her conversion was.
But she did convert
and was baptized.
And so there it is in
the Capitol rotunda,
the "Baptism of Pocahontas."
She looks very lovely
in her white gown.
And the sun is shining through
the window right down upon her.
So we're all good here.
We're all good.
It was another good story.
Pocahontas then went
with her husband
to England, where they
had a child, Thomas Rolfe.
And upon setting out to return
to America, Pocahontas fell ill
and died at the age of 23.
So that's seems like the
end of the story, right?
Well, Pocahontas lives on.
So why is that exactly?
Well, if you go to Virginia,
where I now live, and you throw
a stone down pretty
much any street,
you're going to hit at
least one person who
says they are a direct
descendant of Pocahontas.
And this is fascinating,
right, because it tells us
a couple of things.
But one of them is that people
feel this interesting need
to connect, somehow, to a
Native American heritage.
In Virginia, they
had a huge society
of people who labored
mightily to establish
that they were, in fact,
descendants of Pocahontas.
And I mean, by the
thousands, there
are members of this society.
And all the First
Families of Virginia
wanted to prove they were
descended from Pocahontas.
And they'd pull out the books
and records and all that
and finally put
in an application.
And if you got in, you were
like an uber Virginian.
You weren't just a Virginian.
I mean, were as good as it gets.
Four of the first six
presidents come from Virginia.
So this is no small matter.
These were the aristocrats
of the United States,
and they wanted to be known as
descendants from Pocahontas.
Well, I'll skip past the fate
of the Powhatan Confederacy
except to ask you, when's
the last time you heard
about the Powhatan Confederacy?
In 1924, the state
of Virginia started
thinking about its Jim
Crow laws and decided they
needed a little brushing up.
So they passed a law called
the Racial Integrity Act.
Now, under the
Racial Integrity Act,
there were only two kinds
of people in Virginia.
And it determined
their legal status,
and it's what would show on
any public records regarding
their existence.
You had white people, and
you had colored people.
Now, colored people were
black people, Indians, Asians,
anybody who wasn't 100% white.
And they meant that 100%.
If there was any other
ancestry in your line,
then you were colored.
And needless to say, it was
disadvantageous under Virginia
law to be colored.
But then they thought,
wait a minute.
All of our aristocratic
families have
worked very hard to
establish they're
descended from Pocahontas.
And so they are all colored.
Isn't that awesome?
Well, they were too
clever to let that stand.
So they passed a law that said,
except if you're 1/16 or less
Native American.
Then you can still be a white
person under Virginia law.
And they called it the
Pocahontas Exception.
So you see, Pocahontas has
some real staying power, right?
Pocahontas is still
making news in the 1920s.
So fast forward to the
1960s, and Jim Crow
is still in effect.
The Racial Integrity
Act is still law.
And one of the provisions is
that white people and colored
people may not marry one another
in the state of Virginia.
This law was challenged
by a couple named
Mildred and Richard Loving.
Now, if you read Mildred
Loving's obituary
in "The New York Times,"
it says that Mildred Loving
identified herself as
a Rappahannock Indian.
And in the part of the
state where she came from,
that's not far-fetched at all.
People were there and mixing
for 400 years by that point.
But Mildred thought of herself
as a Rappahannock Indian, not
even as an African-American,
although she was clearly
of African-American
descent, as well.
So Richard and Mildred
challenged the law.
Lo and behold, the
Supreme Court, in 1967,
strikes down the prohibition
on interracial marriage
in Virginia and everywhere else.
Now, that may seem like a
long time ago to some of you.
But not so much to me, because
my parents moved to Virginia
in 1970.
If we'd moved there
three years earlier,
their marriage would have
been prohibited under the laws
of the state of Virginia.
So it's not all that long
ago that these things
were going on.
Then, of course, in the 1990s,
Pocahontas had a good year.
In 1995, she's back in the news,
back in the popular culture.
Disney makes a movie about her.
It's awesome.
All the little girls
could sing the song
where the wind's blowing
through her hair,
and she's grappling with
the moral dilemma of what
her obligations are
to her own people,
as opposed to these lovely
new people from England.
And that becomes, once again,
the story of Pocahontas.
So you see how really
powerful these stories are.
They keep coming back.
And it's just really
interesting to me,
setting aside that it's such
insulting behavior that, when
looking for a name
everybody would recognize
to hurl as an insult against
a non-Indian pretending
to be an Indian, the president
would land on Pocahontas.
So it just gives you an
idea of how deeply ingrained
this stuff is.
So what we're saying-- there
are other origin stories
that we could go into.
The Trail of Tears
in the southeast
is part of their origin story.
As I said, the Indian Wars, and
Little Bighorn in particular,
and here, the gold rush.
We want to do two things.
We know teachers are
teaching about these things.
And because of the material
that's available to them,
we don't expect them to
go out and do the research
and learn all this stuff.
They're kind of busy people.
They're still teaching
it badly, given
what they've got to work with.
But the second thing is there's
a larger concern for all of us,
really, that history is
being taught in this way,
that these stories continue
to be taught as they were
100 years ago and 200 years
ago when the truth is much more
complicated.
And especially in our
increasingly diverse world,
the least we can
do, it seems to me,
is tell our origin stories in
a way that are more inclusive.
Now, this is very
difficult. It sounds easy,
but it's really hard
when you're trying
to construct a narrative.
And so we are grappling
with that right
now, as are other
museums, in how
to tell stories in a way
that is genuinely inclusive
and tremendously complex.
We don't have a lot to
work with, sometimes,
in telling a story.
Nobody wants to stand
there and read what I just
told you on a wall in a museum.
That's incredibly boring,
and the visitors won't do it.
Most of our text, we've
got about 150 words
to work with to make usually
a pretty complicated point.
So we need to get
good at that, though.
That's the challenge
that's before us.
But more generally,
we need people
to be a lot more interested
in the complexities of history
and not just accept
these simple narratives.
The reason our current
political discourse sometimes
seems so stupid and ignorant
is because American students
have not been taught things that
are true about their country.
And so one of the ways that
I've learned to think about it--
and I'm not always
good at it, but I try--
is to basically put myself
in their shoes and say,
the things that these people
believe about our country
are things I used to
believe about our country,
because that's
what I was taught.
And that's what I pick up
in the popular culture.
And so we should be
both humble and generous
in thinking about
it and in talking
about it to others who are
going to be-- let's face it.
They're going to
resist this idea,
because these heroic
narratives are--
did I lose my mic?
These heroic narratives are
so much more satisfying,
whereas the true stories leave
us just a little unsettled.
But I suggest that
maybe unsettled
is the way we should be.
So I'm going to
stop right there.
And by the way,
these are the stories
we need to move
into the classroom.
Now, we don't want to be
teaching fourth graders
about mayhem and murder.
But neither should we
let their only encounter
with Native American history
be a happy, happy story
of happy Indians and white
people all getting along.
We need to start teaching them
early that it's complicated,
and they were just
people, just like us.
And they did good things.
They did bad things.
And we should know
about all of them,
if we're to draw a true
lesson from the history.
So I'm going to stop
and see if anyone would
like to ask some questions.
Or if you'd like me to
just leave, it'd be OK.
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
thanks for the talk.
I had a question.
Are there any lesson
plans that you've either
prepared for teachers or lesson
plans that others had prepared
but that you endorse?
KEVIN GOVER: Oh,
both good questions.
Yes, there are lesson plans
on our website, nmai.si.edu.
And that's the museum's website.
Well, there's a tile for
NK360, or Native Knowledge 360.
But there's only a few, and so
we are trying to populate that.
I mean, we need dozens in
order for it to be adequate.
And we're working on that.
As for others that we
endorse, we haven't yet,
but they are out there.
We've seen some good
material, and another phase
in the project will be to add
those or at least add links
to those resources to the
things we're putting online.
Sir.
AUDIENCE: So there seems
to be a lot of whitewashing
of the history.
Even the terminology,
like American Indian,
seems really whitewashed.
The types of
stories, it's usually
related to Pilgrims
or European colonists
or something like that.
Are there any efforts
to preserve just truly
Native stories?
KEVIN GOVER: Oh, yeah.
Sure.
The Indian nations have
origin myths of their own.
And those don't involve
Columbus or Pilgrims or anything
like that.
So yeah, those
stories are there.
And one thing I will
credit the anthropologists
of the late 19th and
early 20th century with
is they were
incredibly inquisitive,
and they did collect
a lot of stuff.
And so to the extent
those stories did not
survive in the oral tradition
within the community,
they did survive in some
of these library resources.
So yeah.
AUDIENCE: I think you started to
get into this just a little bit
at the very end,
but I was wondering
if you had any more thoughts
on how you would introduce
these stories to
children at a younger age
and at a time when they
really aren't able to absorb
the complexity of it, but
there's some introduction
there to build on later.
Because certainly,
my experience is
that the largest portion of
Native American history I
learned was probably in
second through fifth grade,
and then I spent time
slowly unlearning it.
But they talked about it
less, so it was kind of--
I grew up in Massachusetts,
too, so the whole Pilgrims'
first Thanksgiving was a
big thing that we would
celebrate in elementary school.
KEVIN GOVER: Yeah.
So first of all,
I should quickly
say I'm not an educator
and certainly not
an elementary school educator.
We think about
this all the time.
I'll give you a great example.
I was here a couple of years
ago up in Sonoma County.
And in Sonoma, there is
a mission still standing,
the Sonoma mission,
which is a state park.
It's the only one of the
Catholic missions that
was not returned to the church.
So if you go in there,
there's a little exhibit
with a little bit
of history about it.
They note that the Indians
were not always well treated,
but they don't
really focus on it.
But the real problem
is that there
was a group of kids playing
out in the courtyard
of the mission.
And so I go out to
see what's going on.
And it looked like
it was a fourth grade
class that was there
to visit the mission
and learn some history.
The teachers and the chaperones
were dressed up as priests,
as if they were the priests
of the mission, which
meant that the kids
who were there visiting
were the Indians.
And some of them, in fact,
dressed up as Indians.
And so they were going from
station to station playing.
They were making candles, and
they were weaving baskets,
and they were spinning wool,
and that sort of thing.
And I thought,
again, you don't want
to take fourth graders down
the road of murder and rape.
On the other hand,
there's no way
they should be left-- this
will be their only exposure
to Indians for probably
quite some time
in their formal education.
They shouldn't go away
thinking that the missions were
fun for the Indians, right?
Now, there are ways to
teach, and you sort of pose
questions to children and
say, so what must that
have been like for a child to
be taken from their parents
and made to work in a mission?
What would that be like to have
to work so many hours a day
growing food or doing whatever?
And so yeah, there
are ways to do it.
And we should do it.
We should do it.
Because you know what?
It sucks for those
little kids later
when they begin to
learn, as I did,
that it wasn't a happy story.
And that can be really
quite disconcerting.
AUDIENCE: So thank
you for the talk.
How does the museum
deal with the struggle
between telling other
visitors the history
and connecting them to the
current American Indians who
are living in the reserve and
struggling the North Dakota--
the Keystone Pipeline?
KEVIN GOVER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: There is modern
issues that actual people
who are living--
I feel like sometimes,
going to the museum,
when you are not the
powerful part of the story,
it feels like we are
mythical creatures,
and these people disappeared,
never exist anymore.
And the history, being
good or bad, it's history.
And how does the
museum connect them
to know these
people are actually
real people living
right now and suffering
as they used to suffer?
How does the museum
deal with that?
KEVIN GOVER: Yeah,
that's a great question.
It's the right question, too.
So one of the
consequences of involving
Native people themselves in the
interpretation of the material
is that they won't leave it at,
this is the way it used to be.
They always want to say,
this is how we are now.
One way I could have told the
end of the Pocahontas story
might be that in the past two
years, eight tribes in Virginia
were finally accorded
recognition by the United
States as Indian nations.
They had gone the entire
history of the United States,
despite having obviously been
there from time immemorial,
without being recognized
by the federal government
or eligible for the services
that other Indians received.
So they're still there,
and they're still
working and trying to
succeed as Native people.
The other thing, though,
is we, in our exhibitions,
try not to leave them
in the past, too.
So we have an exhibition
about the history
of treaties between the United
States and the Native nations.
The last portion of the
exhibit, actually, is--
there was a mile marker at
the Standing Rock camp, where
all these different
people were putting up
the names of their tribes
and point a direction
and say how many miles it
was to where they were from.
They gave it to us.
And so that is in our exhibition
about treaties, where we're
saying, treaties still exist.
Native people still exist.
This relationship still exists.
And so now, it's on
us, who are here now,
to say what the next
chapter is going to be.
It's not hard, right?
Indians are generally
invisible in
contemporary American society.
But you just have to
know where to look,
because they're not
invisible to us,
and they're certainly not
invisible in our museum.
Most of our art
exhibitions are actually
contemporary Native art.
And it's as beautiful
and as weird
as other contemporary art is.
SPEAKER 1: Thank
you so much, Kevin.
Thank you so much
for being here.
KEVIN GOVER: You're welcome.
Thank you.
SPEAKER 1: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
And thank you, everyone,
for your questions.